hi I'm Jamie Dornan I'm gal gadotz and
I'm hurt and this is the wired
autocomplete interview
are these real like is this for people
yeah
are you ready I did Gal Gadot become an
actress I was betting law and I was a
model and a casting director flew from
London and she was looking for the Bond
girl and she saw my card on the board
and she said I want to see her and she
didn't cast me for Bond but she cast me
for Fast and the Furious that's how I
started fell in love and never became a
lawyer who would thank God
Barbie Okay
Margo had an interview for one of the
bigger outlets and she was saying how
they wanted to catch me for Barbie and
it wasn't available and maybe for the
next one I hope it says Jimmy Jordan
Barbie
yes I don't know let me guess how tall
am I okay
but I'm wearing heels okay so get off my
health five ten and a half okay
with my heels
is
yes all right
Keira Knightley yes right now you're
talking about my ex-girlfriend let's
dude I think so I'll tell you that uh no
no
I think like we look like sisters who's
talking about in Snow White I'm the evil
queen yeah yeah I'm gonna do Aliyah when
Alibaba started her career I started
acting when I was 18. two years ago no
five 12 years ago amazing
find Alia blood's wedding dress my
wedding dress was designed by sabiasachi
the most celebrated Indian designer and
he did it all in two weeks wow was
alibabad in Met Gala 2023 yes I was at
the Met Gala 2023 it was my first ever
met and it was a fun experience it was
definitely very overwhelming because you
like build that yourself up to that one
moment where you have to like walk the
carpet make sure you don't fall down Etc
but then it's like such a Slaughter
there you go there no you go there there
can you move here and go upstairs it's
so crazy it is it is overwhelming but
when it's all over and then you go and
have dinner and everybody sits down it's
actually quite quite fun and really nice
and we got to see the beautiful
exhibition what alibaba's zodiac sign
ideologies of Love
uh well I'm like great Secret Keeper and
I live in my head and I'm almost never
present she's not here right I'm not
here right now
I'm thinking about my lunch what is
new movie
new movies her first Hollywood movie and
it's called Heart of Stone and it's on
Netflix in the 11th of August drop the
mind okay I'm worried about this what
size does Jamie Dornan have sure
dark blue deep dark blue ocean blue
that's what I mean
sunny day it's baby blue song Ocean eyes
that's kind of what we're seeing it's
about you what did Jamie Donna study at
University Jesus I was only there for a
year what do you think I studied hello
no I'm not that bright
um Finance
just business I started a marketing
degree and I gave up when I realized
that I had no interest in marketing but
here I am marketing myself in the film
Heart of Stone coming to Netflix 11th of
August what has Jamie Dornan starred in
not much I don't know I've been doing
this a long time during my first movie
when I was 22 Marie Antoinette or Sofia
Coppola that was my first film and this
is my first ever audition I just got an
agent like four days before wow and I
feel this she was like oh this is so
easy like I was like
here we go go off through the races and
then barely works
it was a weird way to start what does
Jamie Dornan sing in Belfast I sing
Everlasting Love if you can't give us uh
give us the flavor
Hearts go mystery deep and hurt when
they go there we go
[Music]
this role completely changed my life all
of the sudden
um recognized everywhere I go and I'm
very very grateful and lucky to be the
one to portray this amazing character
thank you though stay in shape girl oh
thank you so much for asking it's all
about balance and moderation and working
out I'm thoughtful with what I eat and
what I consume they work out three four
times a week when I'm not in a project
and that's it thanks is
no I'm not but my daughter is but I'm
good with my life was going to go a
figure skitter a figure skater no why do
people think
I am absolutely no idea I'm trying to
think if I did a movie or if there's a
woman who was skating in Wonder skating
but you're like
have a tattoo no not yet my husband and
I are planning on getting something
there's Alia Bhatt no Telugu Telugu is
the language in India it's also the
language that I shot my film
which went on to win an Oscar the song
um that won the Oscar was in the
language when the Telugu language so I
don't know how to speak fluently but I
know a couple of words
very nice
Alia but wear contact lenses during the
lockdown I was changing my clothes and I
poked my own eye because I was so
distracted and I scratch the score
surface level of my eye basically and
because of that I can never wear lenses
again I can't ever have like colored
eyes there's earlier bath have a cat yes
I do I love cats I have a cat and his
name is
yeah
is Jamie Dawn in the next James Bond I
think it's a clever idea I think it's a
great question I meant to answer that no
nobody's told me that I'm the national
sport I feel the guy I feel like I'd be
the first to know Jamie Dawn and carbs
what the hell what did what's going on I
have cookies I have known for them but I
have I do have a very big calf muscles
I've known for my calves are you serious
do you want to see that yeah we want a
zero cops oh yes oh that's a muscular
card oh my God it's a bit crazy that's
amazing speechless by the way Galaxy
wow how does people know you have
because I occasionally wear shorts
um people see them so they just Google
to see yeah
this is giggle where did Jamie Dornan
grew up in Belfast in Northern Ireland
are you from Belfast
I was born about five I went to school
in Belfast but lived in a place called
Hollywood would you believe yeah I've
been away 22 years now but it's still
very much home does Jamie Dawn and play
the piano badly yeah my wife is a film
composer she's a Pianist play guitar
relatively okay but I wish I was better
way to Jamie Dawn and get married 26th
of April uh 2013. well even I'm in April
married
our anniversary is April
April okay what is Gal Gadot known for
my delicious
I make really good I want but it's not
what I'm known for Wonder Woman what
about your calves what is accent British
what else yeah in it
[Laughter]
people tend to think I'm pretty they do
because I spent a lot of time
what awards has got gonna run now I'm
not gonna remember it none is the Oscar
or the Emmy the different type of awards
what is gal gadot's favorite food I love
mac and cheese I love everything that is
delicious and good now I feel like
having shikshuka chopped salad tahini
and like a beautiful sourdough bread oh
yummy let's order
[Laughter]
can I teach it to you yeah
yes just like me yeah just like we grew
up Neighbors my mom was born in
Birmingham but I've been like I've born
and brought up in India so she spoke
British English with you that your
entire life no my grandmother she lived
in England for like her whole life so my
grandmother has the English accent last
one for Alia
happy that's so cute
why are people Googling but you know
what I understand why they must be doing
that because I have my resting face is
this
I'm very happy and possibly like the
happiest person alive right now
touchwood touchwood all right Jamie
Jamie Dornan Robert Pattinson I've known
Rob forever he's a really good friend I
love him I think he's one of the most
interesting exciting actors around uh
probably at one point was quite jealous
of like early on when we were all
friends back in London and Rob was just
like going places and we sort of worked
yeah I think it's amazing nicest guy in
the world Jamie Dornan Kristen Gray well
that's the character I played in three
Fifty Shades of Gray movies they were a
bit of a hit and yeah that's uh
that's the guy was Jamie Dornan in Games
of Thrones no I was in the Game of
Thrones at all but weirdly I ended up at
the rap party where they shot most of
the show in Belfast yeah and I happened
to be filming something at Belfast Dan
and Dave who created the show I'd met a
few times over the years and then I
bumped into them when I was filming in
there and they're like it's a wrap party
tomorrow after when you come when I feel
a bit weird coming to a show I didn't
have nothing to do with the show anyway
I ended up there
um there's like Paparazzi there and
everything so then everyone's going oh
is he in the finals that wasn't but uh I
love the show Jeremy Dornan Kermit the
Frog I like to do a bit of a Kermit the
Frog and impression only when I say I
sing um The Rainbow Connection I could
for that too can you though I don't need
to do that now because it's online you
want to go check out my Instagram it's
on there okay I'm gonna check Jamie
Jordan's Instagram those were fun
questions I would catch me doing uh
Kermit the Frog other than that it was
great I wouldn't kill that so long thank
you for that until next time thank you
bye-bye
foreign